>>Male Presenter: Hi, I'm Nick Dedina.
I'm with the Music, Google Music Group.
And we are here today with Nick Mason.
Who has done so much in his career besides
working with people like Robert Wyatt and
>>Nick Mason: The Damned.
[laughs]
>>Nick: The Damned, which is big on my list.
He's also been Pink Floyd's longest serving
and I would say probably the original member
of the band.
And been their drummer.
He's an amazing musician.
And, really looking forward to talking to
him.
And, welcome.
>>Nick Mason: Thank you.
[applause]
>>Male Presenter: So, we, I know we've just
had the first batch of Pink Floyd remasters.
We kinda got to jump into there.
And we also have The Wall coming out.
>>Nick Mason: Mm-hm.
>>Male Presenter: What was it like kinda not
only going through your, you know, your history
with the band and all the music you made,
but also going through the vaults and hearing
all this stuff you probably hadn't known about
or hadn't remembered?
>>Nick Mason: Well, fascinating exercise.
Inevitably.
Because that's absolutely true.
You forget the notes that were made.
And it's extraordinary in a way that anything
remains.
Because the tendency was to, just discard
things in the way that, if there'd been sketches
or if there'd been notes on paper.
You just think, at the time, you think the
only thing that matters is the finished product.
The finished album.
And so actually, far more interesting exercise
than I think we ever thought.
>>Male Presenter: so you guys, I know you
started really working with some of the people
before Pink Floyd.
Even kind of officially was a band.
But one of the surprises for me was hearing
the early sessions with Syd Barrett and it
didn't seem like he needed that much of a
run up time for his talent to be exposed.
Those were really good, really strong material.
>>Nick Mason: I think that some writers, some,
someone like Syd was a natural talent.
The interesting thing is, in a way, that if
you look at Roger's first song.
On "Piper at the Gates of Dawn."
"Doctor, Doctor" I mean, no disrespect but
it's not a great song.
But with application, within another album,
his writing set of controls were far more
complex songs.
That really worked.
But it's that thing of, some people it just
comes like that, other people have to work
to it.
>>Male Presenter: So I kind of always thought
you guys were these musos.
You know these just, you really picked up
your instruments and played.
And we had talked a little earlier about,
with The Damned.
And the punk.
But you guys were kind of, it's what you did.
And you really had a proficiency that just
went up.
>>Nick Mason: The last of the gifted amateurs
is what I would say.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Nick Mason: I mean, because I would say,
we, it's one of the interesting differences
I think between then and now.
Is that time, at the time there wasn't anyone
to teach you to play the electric guitar or
rock drums or anything like that.
You listened to something that you heard on
the radio.
And you thought, "How'd they do that?"
[taps on knees] you know.
Whereas now, certainly my experience with
my kids is that at school they can go and
take classes and they can actually sit grades
playing Jimi Hendrix tracks.
It's wonderful.
But it leads to a new level of musicianship,
I think today.
Which, I, has to, I love.
I think it's great.
>>Male Presenter: But there's that balance
between your craft and your creativity, and—
>>Nick Mason: Yeah, yeah.
Like naive painting or something.
In some ways, well, again, interesting that
so often classical players are terribly inhibited
by their training.
And very rarely can break out and improvise.
And there are quite a number of great players
who have wanted to improvise and been absolutely
unable to.
I mean, this is perhaps one of my favorite
stories about the whole experience of doing
these, these editions recently.
But the nicest one was when we were working
on "Wish You Were Here."
We were playing the track and Yehudi Menuhin
and Stephane Grapelli were working in studio.
I think we were in Studio 3 in Abbey Road,
then Studio 2.
And they came in just to see what we were
up to.
And we invited them to play.
And Stephane Grapelli absolutely just went
in and knocked something out.
And that's one of the elements that's in the
package.
And Yehudi would really like to have played
but was far too uneasy at the prospect of
improvising.
And in a way that is, I'd say it's sad.
But that is perhaps the price you pay for
being the virtuoso.
>>Male Presenter: That's one of the real treasures
of that.
>>Nick Mason: Mm-hmm.
>>Male Presenter: Is that, not just his work.
I don't know if you sat, if you guys sat down
with him and told him what the song was about.
>>Nick Mason: God no.
>>Male Presenter: And what the lyrics were
about.
>>Nick Mason: Absolutely no.
Never.
>>Male Presenter: But his solo really fits
the mood and extends.
It does what a solo is supposed to do.
>>Nick Mason: Yeah.
Absolutely.
>>Male Presenter: It spins the emotion of
the piece so beautifully.
>>Nick Mason: Now you just responded to listening
to the track.
>>Male Presenter: So I mean to invite someone
like him in to play with you.
I imagine, you could tell by Pink Floyd's
work, you guys have had such a vast interest
in music.
Not just the, you know, the kind of sharp
subdivisions of music.
What did you listen to growing up?
And how did you eventually get to the drums?
>>Nick Mason: Uh, well, I think all of us
listened to, I mean, the beginnings of rock
and roll.
Which would have been Elvis and Bill Haley
and so on.
I mean, they, it was, well, I can remember
that the first rock and roll that I heard
on the radio, you, the BBC simply didn't play
it.
It was Radio Luxembourg, one hour on a Friday
night.
Called "Rocking to Dreamland," I think.
It was a very small, small thing in Europe
anyway.
And so I think we, that inevitably was the
primary influence.
But I think we probably all listened to, well
perhaps a broader range of music.
Certainly quite a lot of classical music.
But also jazz.
Tried jazz.
And then all the be-bop era stuff.
Certainly in my case.
I had, and still do really, like all the sort
of Charlie Parker, Miles Davis, and so on.
>>Male Presenter: And so this led to you guys,
I mean you were one of the first bands really
and especially first British bands, where
it wasn't something you guys had to do.
Or you felt like it was your option.
You had came from very interesting families.
Your father has, did very interesting work.
And you instead, you guys decided you know,
to play music.
And it started as a lark, or?
>>Nick Mason: Yeah, I suppose the thing is,
well, the sociology of it, if you like.
I suppose we were part of that change where
rock and roll started coming from the middle
classes rather than anywhere else.
And previous to that had been sort of a working
class concept.
And then the, I suppose around earlyish '60s.
And certainly, I'm talking UK always here.
What really happened were the art schools
started turning up the bands.
And that includes a band called The Pretty
Things who were one of the earliest of those.
But the Beatles certainly had an element of
the art school.
And certainly, and the Rolling Stones were
sort of a college band rather than sort of
working class off the railways which had been
the early English rock scene.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah, I read a thing with
Mick Jones of "The Clash".
Where he said he went to art school because
he wanted to be in a rock and roll band.
And he didn't know how to do it and that's
where he heard you did it.
>>Nick Mason: [laughs]
>>Male Presenter: And he said as a byproduct
of that, he got a great art education.
And used that for the sleeves and the costumes.
[inaudible]
>>Nick Mason: Yeah.
Well, I have to say for, I mean, we weren't
quite art school.
We were architecture school.
And it was absolutely brilliant training.
I mean, first of all, it was a sort of government
funded initiative.
In that we got a grant to go.
Architecture's a very long course.
So you've got sort of a good seven years.
If it was gonna take a while to learn some
of those drum patterns.
[laughter]
And also in our case it led to a lot of other
spinoffs in terms of people that we later
worked with who were not necessarily musicians
but became lighting designers, stage designers.
Best known of all is Mark Fisher.
Who did the original designs for The Wall
and the mechanics of the way The Wall worked.
And fell down and all the rest of it.
Mark was a contemporary of ours.
He was at the AA which was the other architectural
school in London.
>>Male Presenter: So that's another element
you guys kind of brought was, I mean, I think
maybe Alice Cooper later.
Your, there's the element of your music and
then there's the element of your life, presentation,
which certainly evolved over the years.
>>Nick Mason: Uh, yeah.
>>Male Presenter: Was that a conscious or—
>>Nick Mason: I'm just making the connection
with Alice Cooper and thinking about the snakes.
[laughter]
We never really did snakes.
Sorry.
What—
>>Male Presenter: No, but there was a, I don't
know if it was part of the British underground
scene but there always seemed to be your stage
shows there was more elements to your stage
shows than—
>>Nick Mason: Well, I think that was, yeah,
that was again, that was connected to the
architecture element.
Because there was, we had a part time lecturer
who spent half the time at Hornsey College
of Art and half the time at Regent Street.
And he was working at Hornsey, with light
and sound workshops.
The idea of these light shows being the sort
of potential of the next paintings hanging
on the walls.
And we went and supplied music for this.
This exercise at Hornsey.
And this didn't come out of our school at
all, funnily enough.
And that was sort of about being right place,
right time.
I mean I think most bands need, I think all
bands actually need that mix.
I mean however good you are or however bad,
you need to be, in the right place at the
right time.
You know two years earlier, wouldn't have
happened.
Two years later it wouldn't have happened.
>>Male Presenter: So what's the film?
It's a wonderful movie uh, "Blowup?"
>>Nick Mason: Oh yes.
>>Male Presenter: Blowup.
I mean, seeing that as an American now, I
think it's supposed to be very glamorous and
you realize London is still coming out of
a war.
There's still like bomb sites in the film
and it's a little shabby.
But I always use that as a kind of thing that
maybe the world that Pink Floyd was involved
in.
Or?
>>Nick Mason: I think, well we were sort of
slightly, we were sort of mid-60s, I suppose.
Now, I think we were into this new, I mean,
it was the London underground.
But it was also that change where younger
people were actually making money.
And this was the big change.
I mean up until when England came out of that
whole post-war period, up until then, young
people were apprentices.
I mean was the sort of thinking, more or less.
And suddenly they had this thing with these
particularly, I mean, before us, the young
photographers and the whole sort of old fashioned
thing.
As well as the music.
It was a pretty broad brush.
And it was you know, it was the '60s. we were
all really worried about what we were gonna
do with all our free time.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: So that's one of the differences
between Britain and America at that time.
It just seems to be the amount of money the
consumer had, or what materials cost.
But I think an outshoot of that was, at that
time Britain was more singles orientated and
America was more LP orientated.
>>Nick Mason: Yeah, I mean, not, again, I
can only, my experience is England.
And the key moment was really Sergeant Pepper
and that was back, because that was the moment
at which the album sales overtook the singles.
And that was an absolute change.
And again, that's, that comes back to what
I was saying earlier.
We were right place, right time.
Because the way we worked was really suited
to the concept of working on an album basis
rather than a single basis.
I mean, our first recordings were absolutely
geared to the idea that we had to have the
hit single.
>>Male Presenter: And that's strange, kind
of, coming, 'cause, I have no idea, I mean
200 million, 300 million albums for Pink Floyd?
Which is phenomenal.
But you guys have never been perceived as
a singles band.
An LP band.
But at the beginning, maybe you—
>>Nick Mason: At the beginning we were.
We decided we were an album band when we couldn't
sell the singles.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: Well, how was that transition?
I know you brought in and old member.
And then you brought in David Gilmore.
When Syd Barrett was starting to have troubles
or trouble with the band.
How was that and what did you see in David
Gilmore to invite him aboard?
>>Nick Mason: Um, what did we see in David?
Well, that's a fairly multipart question.
Uh, in no particular order.
Well I always like to say that we really wanted
the best guitarist available.
But he wasn't, so we picked David.
[laughter]
But that's being unkind.
But no, David was perfect.
Partly because of great voice.
Great guitar player.
And actually out of work at the time.
We actually thought he was rather possibly
too good for us I think.
But he was driving a van at the time for Ossie
Clark.
So he was sort of, we sort of guessed that
he'd be up for it.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah and then how was that
transition when there seems to be that there's
a parting of ways between Syd Barret and Pink
Floyd?
>>Nick Mason: Yeah.
Uh.
Very British.
Very Pink Floyd, in that we tried not to address
it at all.
[laughter]
And you know the famous story is that we,
which is true, which is that Syd was absolutely
having a breakdown.
And in a, again, very British way we tried
to ignore it.
By occasionally sort of saying "Alright, well,
let's take a day off."
Which is really not the solution at all.
Um, and it just got more and more difficult
for him to operate actually, rather than work
with us or anything like that.
He was really falling apart.
And we were, as I say, just trying to ignore
it.
And finally one day, we'd done three or four
shows with David on board as well.
As a five-piece.
And we just said, "You know what, let's just
not pick Syd up today."
And went off and carried on doing the shows
without him.
Well, of course, very soon it all had to be
resolved.
But it was a sort of strange moment.
But of course, once we, once Syd had dropped
out and we were working with David.
It was a real, it was another kick start.
It was almost like starting again.
It was actually terrific for us really.
Because we were all motivated.
And we all knew exactly what we wanted to
do together.
And it made life really easy.
We still have to carry the guilt I think.
The fact that we were not prepared to recognize
that Syd was in trouble and having this breakdown.
And we should have done something about it
far far earlier.
But we weren't very good at it at the time.
>>Male Presenter: Well I imagine one of the
things that's hard is, you're dealing with
Syd on a personal, you know, business level.
And other people have kind of sainted him
and his work as perfect.
And you, you know, in its time, he didn't
keep going the way you guys did.
But it seems like you really, your personality
started coming out more as you know, after
he—
>>Nick Mason: Yeah, well I think Syd was absolutely
the leader of the band.
He was the writer.
Wrote all the good songs.
And he was the front man.
What's strange in a way, was that we absolutely
thought we could carry on without him.
Because we had no history of other songwriters.
Roger taking over or Rick writing, really.
But there was, there still was the sort of
curious drive to keep going.
There was something that we thought we could
do.
>>Male Presenter: So this is kind of a period
where, in Britain, you guys are having kind
of a great deal of success right out the gate.
I mean.
>>Nick Mason: Well, we had a couple of, we
did have sort of a semi-hit single.
Or a couple of relatively successful records.
The big thing though was this business of
working live.
And actually in the UK, it wasn't that great.
I mean, we were the sort of you know, this
new wonderful exciting underground music.
That everyone in London thought was incredibly
cool and smart and everyone outside London
thought it was truly ghastly.
And you know.
[laughter]
We were quite often more or less booed off
the stage but not the most popular act that
had been there.
And we, again, it's this, I don't wish to
make my career sound as though it was entirely
based on luck, but there's an element of what
happened at the same time, was that the new
universities, all the red brick universities,
were starting to understand that one of the
ways the student unions could operate was
to put on these shows.
And so all these universities sort of became
a whole touring thing.
And instead of having to do these top rank
ballrooms which were full of soul bands playing
"Knock on Wood" rather badly, we'd do these
universities where all these intense students
would sit and listen to the music.
Which was exactly the audience we needed.
And the other thing at the same time was that
we were working in Europe.
And in particular in France.
The French embraced us.
And really, the French perhaps sort of, French
and Dutch probably particularly, really gave
us a living.
We might not have had it entirely in the UK.
>>Male Presenter: So yeah, at this time in
the States we had, FM radio had started.
>>Nick Mason: Mm-hmm.
>>Male Presenter: And there wasn't corporate
control.
The DJs could play what they wanted to.
>>Nick Mason: Wonderful.
>>Male Presenter: So they were playing the
long, there weren't edited Pink Floyd cuts.
They were playing the long Pink Floyd cuts.
>>Nick Mason: Oh brilliant.
I remember when we first came over in '67.
The whole thing of doing the FM radio shows.
It was just wonderful.
Drive out to this shack and there'd be this
guy with this fantastic record collection.
It would be sort of two or three hours of
putting stuff on.
There's still quite a famous tape, I think,
of a radio show in Philadelphia.
Where we went to this FM station after we'd
finished doing a show.
We were supporting The Who.
And we went out to this radio station with
Keith.
And Pete.
And Roger, myself and Rick, I think.
And I think we might have had a few drinks
or something might have happened.
[laughter]
But there's the sound of Rick going "I don't
like this record."
And sort of just ripping it out of the turntable.
[laughter]
Good times.
>>Male Presenter: So, and you guys were involved
with film, too.
I mean, you did some sound tracks.
Which I don't know if they were big at the
time or not.
But they're beloved now.
In, when, especially "Obscured by Clouds"
kind of really almost brings you to another,
you know, new sounds.
How did you get involved with that?
>>Nick Mason: IT was, well, the first film
that we did a proper soundtrack for was Barbet
Schroeder.
"More."
And, I think, we'd sort of established the
idea that we liked working with images.
And weren't very interested in learning to
do moon walking or anything like that.
And so there was a sort of natural link really.
To film.
And Barbet was perfect.
Because again, there was the French connection.
In so much as that he was really up for using
us rather than anyone else.
And he also was very relaxed about how it
was done.
It was done relatively low budget and that,
people I don't think at that time had invented
[indistinct] or any of the smart ways of linking
music.
So what we actually did was, we would go and
watch the film in its current edit.
And then we would simply time sections.
So we'd go "We need 17 and a half seconds
of this sort of feel to the music."
And we'd go into the studios and record this
sort of thing.
And then go back and Barbet would sort of
fit it.
And if necessary maybe modify the film slightly
and sometimes we'd just make cross fades that
were long enough for the film to actually
be a second and a half out.
They weren't very tight cues.
It was, I think it worked really well.
And I think that gave us a real taste for
it.
We then went home and did,The Valley, "Obscured
by Clouds" was the one after that.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah, in "Obscured by Clouds"
there is a wonderful records you guys did
called "Meddle."
Which I know as a lot of my friends, it's
one of their favorite Pink Floyd records.
Where it seems like you guys again, took another
leap.
Where it was just a, almost, if you when you
listen to "Obscured by Clouds" too, those
will almost like coalesce into "Dark Side
of the Moon."
>>Nick Mason: Yeah, I have to say, I tend
to think if you look at the progression of
albums, "Meddle" is quite critical.
It goes sort of "Piper", "Saucer", and then
more or less "Meddle."
So I think "Ummagumma" and “Atom Heart Mother”,
are both sort of cul-de-sacs.
That we were good to do.
And I'm not ashamed of the records but in
terms of the progression, "Meddle" certainly
was that, the sort of idea that you could
have a piece that was the entire side of an
album.
That that would actually be a good way of
working rather than not.
>>Male Presenter: So, how did you guys approach
"Dark Side of The Moon?"
Were you consciously thinking "This is gonna
be it?
This is our moon shot here?"
>>Nick Mason: That would be great.
If we'd all sat around and just gone "I know
what, let's make a record that would be in
the top 100 for the next 30 years."
[laughter]
That would be very smart.
Smart programming.
No, we wanted, we were going to make the next
record.
And we started talking about the idea of doing
something that was a bit more than just individual
tracks.
I think probably initially we had got two
or three individual tracks.
With some ideas.
And then we actually talked about the idea
of doing something and giving it this theme.
And the theme would be, things that make life
difficult.
Four long haired youths doing drugs and alcohol,
talking about what makes life difficult may
sound a bit odd now.
[laughter]
But at the time, we just sort of sat about
talking about mortality and money and so on.
And once we'd sort of got a vague idea of
what we were going to try and do, Roger went
off to write lyrics.
And on the various subjects.
And it began to sort of fit together really.
I still think it's interesting on that record.
And it's one of the reasons why I think the
record has survived for so long.
Is this very curious thing that Roger had
the ability to write lyrics that quite often
are more relevant to a 50 year old than to
a 20 something year old.
You know it's particularly some of the lines,
you can listen to now and think "Yeah, yeah,
well that—" kicking away the moments that
make up a dull day”.
I mean it's as relevant perhaps more relevant
now than then.
>>Male Presenter: I don't know if it's his,
because of Syd Barrett.
Or because of Roger Waters, kind of had a
prickly personality.
>>Nick Mason: That's one way of putting it.
They said the same about Stalin.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: But he, especially on that
album, those lyrics are, they are pointed.
And I can think of other things that kind
of, it's an album I took one way as a child
and another way today.
How did that affect your career?
Because I would imagine, that album is the
second biggest selling album of all time.
And it hasn't lost an ounce of relevance or,
hasn't dated at all.
How did that affect especially your career?
And Pink Floyd, and in America?
>>Nick Mason: Well, it transformed everything
for us.
Because success in America is what matters.
in rock music.
And so it pushed us suddenly from league division
2, to the premier league.
Which meant of course that we could then change
our shows into something far more advanced.
I mean, that's, you know, that's how it works.
You can then get the best people to help you
do the staging.
Bigger shows.
I think it made life difficult in other ways
because you then lurch from theater shows
to arena shows to stadium shows.
The stadium shows require a very different
approach.
I mean now, well, you know.
You see it, having watched Madonna yesterday.
I mean, it's the stadium show, it's a fantastic
thing that people can do relatively, I won't
say simply.
But everyone's sort of familiar with how it
works and how to make it work.
But at the time, the lurch into stadiums was
not good.
Because the requirement for the staging in
order to keep the focus on the stage, is huge.
And you tended to find that you'd still, you
got half the stadium who were watching the
show, and the rest of them were playing Frisbee
at the back or whatever.
[soft laughter]
Which is not so good.
The other problem with it was of course that
we then had to do the follow-up album.
And I think we got there in the end, but being
wiser after the event, what we should have
done was a lot more touring and a lot more
live, we should have played "Dark Side" live
more.
And filmed it.
It's one of the great regrets that we didn't
really ever have a record of how we did it
originally.
And it meant that we actually spent a year
in the studio not getting anywhere.
It actually, the first six, nine months of
recording of "Wish You Were Here" produced
absolutely nothing.
And we just finished recording a sort of "How
we did it" DVD.
And four more miserable people
[laughter]
That you'd hope to interview, going "Yeah,
well, I thought.
Oh God, what are we gonna do now?" and so
on.
It was a pretty average time really.
>>Male Presenter: But it's almost ironic because
it feels as if "Dark Side" would have been
the struggle and there's "Wish You Were Here"
is a more melancholy record.
>>Nick Mason: Mm-hmm.
>>Male Presenter: Well, they're actually both
pretty melancholy records.
>>Nick Mason: [laughs] Yeah, we don't really
do "The Sound of Music."
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
But there's a lightness and it doesn't feel
like a struggle.
It feels, it's almost like you guys went back
to some of the elements in "Meddle" too.
>>Nick Mason: Yeah, it's hard to remember
exactly.
I don't know that the struggle was perhaps
the period before it.
Just before we actually hit some ideas and
actually had something to do.
But "Dark Side" wasn't really a struggle.
No, it was actually probably the point at
which we worked at our best together.
In terms of getting something done and getting
it right.
>>Male Presenter: I would say growing up that
"Money" was always played on the radio.
And then of course "Another Brick in the Wall."
But today, "Wish You Were Here" is probably
the most played on every radio format.
You'll be listening to a Mexican ranchero
station and suddenly "Wish You Were Here"
will pop up.
It's become like a gold standard.
>>Nick Mason: Well, always nice to here.
But it is curious.
Because you know, you look back on these things
and actually then to try and sort of make
some sense of why they work or why they don’t
work is almost impossible really.
>>Male Presenter: And then when the kind of
punk explosion happened, um, I always think
it's kind of funny that Pink Floyd is thought
of as just about the darkest band imaginable,
and you guys put out "Animals".
>>Nick Mason: Mm-hmm.
>>Male Presenter: Which was, I mean the punk
scene comes out as light and airy compared
to that album.
>>Nick Mason: [laughs]
>>Male Presenter: I mean it was that?
>>Nick Mason: Yeah, well, we've ruminated
a bit on "Animals" and whether it was influenced
by punk.
And I suspect it was to some extent.
That there was I think, even we were recognizing
that there was this sort of prog-rock, punk-rock,
everything had got a bit overblown and everyone
was building bigger and bigger sets.
And it was not really the way everyone wanted
to go.
So there was an element of that influence.
And the fact that we were absolutely pilloried
is the wrong word, but attacked by the sort
of punk movement.
As being these sort of old has-beens.
And there was that feeling of, "Well we'd
better respond to this."
But actually it was also part of a change
in the way we recorded.
Because for this album we'd build our own
recording studio.
And it was not in Abbey Road.
It was a much much simpler, much more basic
recording facility.
And I think that had an influence on it as
well.
>>Male Presenter: So, I think it was a little
after "Animals" you worked with The Damned.
So here's a punk band.
I don't know if it's just Captain Sensible
who's always named Pink Floyd as the highest
of, he just completely adores them.
Whether it was his influence or the whole
band, but how was that?
Going from you were kind of stadium heroes,
to working with them.
>>Nick Mason: Well I absolutely loved it.
I think I got more out of it than they did.
Because as so often happens, well, the truth
of the matter is that The Damned had approached
our publishing company.
Because they actually wanted Syd to produce
their record.
And that was not going to happen.
So they said "Well, Syd's not available.
We've got an old drummer who'll do it."
And so I was really interested but unfortunately
the band were in the middle of having musical
difference.
And so there was a big split.
Between, I think it was Brian and Dave Vanian
on one side and Captain and Rat on the other.
So I spent quite a lot of time waiting for
them to sort of finish a fight before we could
get on and do something.
But I loved that business of making the record
in a week or so.
And I'd say to the Captain, after three takers
I'd say "I think that's really good.
Why don't we do another one?"
And he'd got "Naaaah.
Why?
Naaaah.
That's fine."
And I loved that.
I mean actually you end up with the sort of
energy that you never get from doing 27 takes
and 40 overdubs.
>>Male Presenter: So when you guys moved to
The Wall, which if anything, I don't know
about it in Britain, but that at the time
became probably even bigger than "Dark Side
Of The Moon."
I mean, we had, we were, I took a yellow school
bus.
And you'd have 50 American kids singing along
to that on AM radio.
>>Nick Mason: [laughs]
>>Male Presenter: But was there a difference
in the band dynamics when the album came out?
>>Nick Mason: No, well, there was by the time
the album was finished.
But I think when we started on it, it was
fairly, we were in a relatively good place.
In so much as that it was a different, it
was different.
Because Roger had actually produced demos
of the whole thing.
It was a whole concept rather than bits and
pieces.
And even put together.
And so we actually knew what it was gonna
be.
We'd all agreed that that's what we wanted
to do.
And so it was fine.
We were then sort of thrown into disarray
because we moved to France rather rapidly
when we discovered that we'd lost a lot of
money and that the Inland Revenue were going
to possibly come and take our houses and cars
and all the rest of it.
We thought this was a very bad idea.
So we headed for France.
Which in another way was a good thing.
Because it meant that we were really, suddenly
had to focus on what we were doing.
We might have taken a year longer, I think,
to record it if we'd just done it in England.
In between doing all the other things we were
doing at the time.
But a lot of "The Wall" recording was actually
really good and really exciting.
Because we brought in all these other people
to get involved and help.
We'd got James Guthrie doing sound.
We'd got Bob Ezrin helping with production.
And later on we had Michael Kamen doing the
string arrangements.
So working with all these people was terrific.
And we were working in the south of France
which is never a bad thing.
Compared to London anyway.
Um, so it was all fairly good.
It began to fragment much further along the
line.
When there were disagreements between Roger
and Rick in particular about when we were
going to work and when we weren't or whatever.
And then it sort of all blew up just about
the time that we were finishing the record.
But the actual process of making a lot of
the record was, I won't say easy.
But it was perfectly civilized.
>>Male Presenter: It's, that's a record that
seems to speak to teenagers and yet it's,
and American teenagers.
But it's so much, pretty much all your work,
it's such an English record.
And it seems to be such an, it's almost like
the more specific you are, the more universal
you are.
Because it seems to be such a singular story
and it affects everyone else.
How did, did you guys feel any pressure about
that being your story?
Or did you just feel that you're in a band?
>>Nick Mason: No, I think that's interesting.
I think going back to this business of Roger
playing the demo.
He actually played us two demos.
He played the demo of "The Wall" and the demo
of "Hitchhiker".
And actually we all sort of responded to "The
Wall" rather than "Hitchhiker" and felt that
it spoke to us.
As well as it was very autobiographical in
certain ways.
Very strong elements of very specific moments
in Roger's life.
But I think we felt that they, it had moments
that hit us as well.
Particularly.
So it was very easy to engage in the whole
thing.
And get involved in it, from that point of
view.
>>Male Presenter: And was that another, I
know the tour at that time was just considered
this, I mean, a true spectacle.
Which--.
>>Nick Mason: It was a madness.
That's what it was.
Because it was a show that could never make
any money.
It was done absolutely as a sort of as part
of a bigger plan actually of course.
Which was to do the show and then eventually
film it.
And then that changed in the end with the
way the whole thing was.
Well, just the way it all panned out.
Now I think if you ask Roger now.
I think Roger wouldn't necessarily have chosen
to let it go down the path that it did.
It was sort of overtaken by the fact that
when we did film some of the London shows
it still didn't do whatever was really required.
And we ended up taking Alan Parker who was
a sort of [indistinct] originally.
I don't think he really wanted the job but
felt that he really had to take it.
And so he ended up directing it and changing
it into much more of a feature film.
>>Male Presenter: Which was very successful
too.
All those play doors, and, there was a time
with Pink Floyd that you guys were so popular
week after week, month after month, year after
year, that they actually changed the charts
in America
>>Nick Mason: [laughs]
>>Male Presenter: basically to take Pink Floyd
records off of it because you were stopping
other bands from getting exposure.
>>Nick Mason: So American.
[laughter]
Get rid of those damned Europeans coming over
here.
[laughter]
Yeah, there were a number of quite nice things.
I think what still, I think there was some
altercation between the record company and
the billboard.
They wouldn't take the extra advertising.
So we were never given more than a gold record.
Rather than a platinum also.
Something like that.
But I don't think it's something that we lose
a lot of sleep over.
No.
>>Male Presenter: And then, the final cut,
which I know was a contentious record.
With the band.
Is one of those albums I think the same way
that "Dark Side of the Moon's" kind of existential
themes, kind of, there's no time in for them.
That album, with the kind of the debt crisis
we're going through.
The wars we're going through.
It's still, it's suddenly speaking to people
again.
In a, you know, in a way that, especially
in America it didn't during the beginning
of Thatcherism and whatnot.
>>Nick Mason: Yeah, in many ways it was quite
a political record.
I think it was, well Roger always describes
it.
He's fond of it but he will concede it's flawed.
Which I think is quite a good way of putting
it.
But it's got one or two sort of quite interesting
side aspects to it.
One of which is something that's I've always
sort of being sorry about in a way, that we
used up some new technology on that.
Some quad technology.
Developed by a guy called Hugo Zuccarelli.
I think his name was.
And it was this absolutely mind blowing quadraphonic
kind of thing.
That only required a stereo mic.
It actually had a, I say a "human head".
It wasn't a real human head.
But it modeled a human head with all the ear
ducts.
And it was stunningly good in terms of surround
sound.
I mean, I remember it still.
Sitting there and listening to this.
And we never managed to actually get this
technology onto the record properly.
But it was a sort of side aspect to the thing
itself.
But having been involved in quite a lot of
the sound effects that we used on the record,
lot of sounds, Doppler effect, traffic, and
things like aircraft and so on.
It's something that I'm really sorry we were
never able to actually engineer into the record
itself.
>>Male Presenter: So when you guys carried
on as Pink Floyd without Roger Waters, and
then just one last question before we open
it to the audience members.
>>Nick Mason: Mm-hmm.
>>Male Presenter: But how was it, it was so
nice to see you guys do the Live Aid performance
and, together.
And for a really appropriate cause.
Did that, did that whole performance mend
some fences?
Or?
>>Nick Mason: Oh yeah.
No, it was a very good thing to do.
And well it was a brilliant thing to do really.
Because it was playing for all the right reasons.
It showed we could be vaguely grown up.
And I was able to say to my children "Look,
see we're not that bad."
No, it was terrific.
And I think everyone came away with all the
right feelings from that.
>>Male Presenter: That's wonderful.
>>Nick Mason: But no we are not announcing
a new Pink Floyd tape.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: Well, just
[audience member sneezes]
Bless you.
One more thing before we open to the crowd.
I was at a super bowl game last night and
I mentioned I'd be talking to you, and I expected
some oohs and ahs about Pink Floyd and instead
my friend, Matt, got very excited and ran
to his bookshelf and took off this copies
of Octane Magazine.
>>Nick Mason: [laughs]
>>Male Presenter: That he keeps because he
loves your articles so much.
>>Nick Mason: Ah, excellent.
And I have to say, one of the things that
came out of the whole thing was that I found
that I really did rather enjoy writing.
And I started work on, well, it would have
been '94 I guess.
At the end of the tour.
And started work on doing a sort of autobiography,
story of the band thing.
Which took a while to work with what was acceptable
with the others or not.
And people said "How'd they feel about it?"
And I tend to say the book has been almost
universally acclaimed, and when I say "almost
universally", there are three people who don't
like it.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: it's a really fun book.
And a really beautiful book.
>>Nick Mason: Thank you.
But as I say, I just ended up really enjoying
the business of writing.
And ended up doing quite a lot of car journalism
as well.
Fun.
>>Male Presenter: Well, thanks.
Do we have any questions?
>>Male #1: Hi Nick.
>>Nick Mason: Hi.
>>Male #1: Oh.
So in the late '90s or so, the news kind of
broke out that there was probably some sort
of sync between "Dark Side of the Moon" and
"Wizard of Oz." [laughter] And then you were
famously quoted as saying "We didn't purposely
sync it up to Wizard of Oz, we sunk it up
to The Sound of Music."
[laughter]
>>Nick Mason: Yeah.
No I, sorry, sorry.
>>Male #1: Just wanted to know, like, is there
actually and intent to sync up to "A Dark
Side of the Moon" and "Wizard of Oz"?
Or is it a coincidence?
Or something that you know, some stoned kid
just read way too much into?
>>Nick Mason: Well, the thing is, it was very
strange.
Judy Garland came into the studio and she
said "I've got this idea for a record."
[laughter]
And it just went from there.
No, it's just one of those peculiar things.
I mean, I think, anyone who works with film,
movie, whatever, and music knows how easily
you can tie things together actually.
The strange thing is this business of odd
cues that work.
But I'm sort of got a feeling you could do
the same with The Wall and Spartacus.
And you know, it depends on how much time
you've all got.
I mean if you've really got that sort of time.
I don't know, I think possibly I'd suggest
you do something else with it.
[laughter]
>>Male #1: Thank you.
>>Male #2: How important was Alan Parsons
as a creative influence on Dark Side?
>>Nick Mason: Um, Alan was, well he was, I
think the best thing with Dark Side is, rather
than try to assign very specific amounts of
importance is just to say, the reason why,
one of the reasons why Dark Side has worked
so well is because it had so many people doing
good things.
I mean I think we'd all say that we were really
lucky to get Alan.
He was the best of that Abbey Road sort of
system.
Almost.
Where he'd worked his way through the system
so he was a really accomplished engineer.
But he was also familiar with all the technology
that was going on at the time.
There was certainly an element of the producer
in him.
As he proved conclusively with the Alan Parsons
Project.
You know, I mean, it was again, it's just
that business of sort of real life.
We assumed that Alan would be engineering
our next record.
And of course, when we announced this good
news to him he went "Well, actually, I want
to be a producer now.
Thank you very much."
And went off and did the project.
So we sort of slightly grew out of each other.
But we were very lucky to have him.
And without a doubt, he plays a very important
role.
As did Chris Thomas.
As did a lot of the unsung heroes of Abbey
Road.
The guys in the white coats who came and fixed
things and came and fiddled with things to
make them work.
You know, I'm thinking again, it sort of relates
to the Beatles when they discovered phasing
and flanging and so on.
It wasn't only George Martin or the Beatles
themselves.
There'd be guys there who would invent things.
I mean, the, when we were recording Piper,
there was a guy there called Bernard Speight.
Who was an engineer.
He was just the engineering department.
But he built for us the original quadraphonic
hand part.
And you know, that just came because there.
Because they had all the bits and pieces in
the workshop.
And because we talked about him.
And it's those sort of things that add immeasurably
to what you're doing.
And of course they never get the medal or
the due recognition.
>>Male #2: Thank you.
>>Male #3: Hi Nick.
Is this on?
Oh there.
I went to the Animals concert in Anaheim Stadium
where it rained right before the concert came
on.
And it seemed, the sun came out and there
was a double rainbow over the stage.
And it seemed like you guys came out early
just to take advantage of the double rainbow.
[laughter]
At least, seemed like that to us.
Was that true?
Or is that just coincidence?
[laughter]
>>Nick Mason: Can you remind me what you were
taking at the time?
[laughter]
>>Male #3: It seemed like, it was scheduled
for eight o'clock and you guys came out at
like five minutes to eight and there was a
couple of—
>>Nick Mason: We might well have done, I mean,
if there's one thing we've learned it's to
take advantage of the weather when you can.
Because my God, we've done some shows in truly
terrible situations.
And, no, there is something wonderful when
it does work.
When you get the weather and it's open air
or whatever.
It's always special.
It's great.
>>Male #3: Thanks.
>>Male #4: Yeah, I was curious, to what degree
or maybe rather in which way were psychedelic
experiences relevant as inspirations for your
music.
>>Nick Mason: I think to almost no measure
at all.
I think actually what happened with, we were
really scared off, well, acid in any form
by Syd's experiences.
Because no one knows for sure, but it certainly
seemed like part of the, of Syd's sort of
psychosis was brought on by overuse of LSD.
And I think that put us on the rum and black
currant for quite a while before we decided
to go experimenting anywhere else.
And certainly, so for the earlier records,
I think to a very small extent.
>>Male #5: you're a band that has a lot of
cover versions of some of your songs.
Especially "Comfortably Numb."
I'm curious if you've heard any of them and
whether you like listening to reinterpretations?
Or whether it's painful to hear somebody else's
version of your stuff?
>>Nick Mason: Um, actually I love reinterpretations
of it.
I mean, "Dub Side of the Moon."
The Scissor Sisters, Eric Pritts.
Even Luther Wright and the Wrongs.
Anyone familiar with?
[laughter]
For anyone who doesn't know, Luther Wright
and the Wrong's country western.
They've done "The Wall" as a complete piece
in country western style.
I mean, that's something.
[laughter]
Actually, I'm far more ambivalent about tribute
bands.
Because for me, music has always been about
sort of doing your own thing.
And sort of the creative side of it.
And I'm a little uncomfortable about people
copying every mistake I've very made.
[laughter]
You know that's something you just think "No,
no, do it your own way."
And they are, and I have to say some of them
are absolutely brilliant.
The most impressive of all has got to be,
I think it's the Australian Pink Floyd.
Who have split, having had musical differences.
[laughter]
You know, you'd thought they'd seen it coming.
>>Male #6: Hey, can you tell us about Live
In Pompeii?
>>Nick Mason: Live in Pompeii.
Interesting because when it was suggested,
we had no, we were not that interested.
I mean it seemed like quite a good idea.
I mean, but now, to have a record of that
show done in that way, is something I think
to be really grateful for.
We hadn't thought it through at all.
It was Adrian Maben the director.
Who decided.
Had this idea of using the amphitheater and
so on.
But what was curious about it was that, I
think that what really worked was that we
didn’t have the complications of doing a
real live show.
So we could cut.
And film, and move cameras around and all
the rest of it.
But it still had a live feel to it.
Which I think all the dust and the open air
element gave it.
We couldn't have done it in a studio.
But the open air element made it into something
else.
I love it.
Of course I also particularly love it because
apparently when they were filming "One of
these Days" there's an awful lot, for people
who've seen the film, there's a lot of tracking
'round the drum kit with me playing.
And apparently they lost some reels of film
which were of the others playing.
[laughter]
So it's a bit of a drum feature.
>>Male #7: I've always been intrigued by "Money"
and whenever I hear it I envision the point
when the band is sitting together and someone
comes up and says, "I know we're gonna make
a song in seven four time.
And release it to the public."
Can you give any insight about that moment?
And these weird time signatures and?
>>Nick Mason: I think it was Roger just playing
on a guitar.
And coming up with this idea.
And really, I'm not sure he even realized
whether it was seven or whatever.
But I think it was just a sort of idea.
And for some reason, even me, no, even I,
felt that it was a good idea.
And I've never been sort of, certainly that
period, never really dealt with anything other
than four four.
So it was, there was a rather steep learning
curve to it.
But it was a sort of interesting idea just
to be played.
And then what Roger and I worked on the, on
some tape loops.
To actually make the original sort of the
start of the song.
The rhythm track almost for the start of the
song.
And it's got, it's just one of those things
where after you played it enough times you
just think, oh yeah, now that's six, perfectly
comfortably.
But it was very odd when we used to play it
live and people would occasionally try and
dance to it.
[laughter]
>>Male #7: Did you have any problems with
the record executives?
Saying, you know--
>>Nick Mason: Not about that.
I mean.
[laughter]
I think over many many years there's always
been moments where the record company have
had trouble with something we wanted to do.
Actually they've had more trouble and there
probably are record people here who know perfectly
well that actually what we did to make life
a lot easier to ourselves was, we introduced
them to Storm Thorgerson.
And Storm and Hipgnosis made life far more
difficult I think for the record company than
the music side of it ever did.
>>Male Presenter: Well, everyone, let us give
a nice thank you to Nick Mason.
[applause]
>>Nick Mason: Thank you.